This tiny insect is called
a sharpshooter. Why you ask?
Well, sharpshooters fling their pee and what's
more they do it using some pretty nifty physics
called super-propulsion. And according to
the researchers studying these critters,
they may be the only known animal that can do it.
Sharpshooters feed by sucking up nutrients
from xylem, the tubes which plants use to
transport water. But xylem fluid is about 95%
water, so to get enough calories sharpshooters
need to consume a lot. And drinking that much
water means making a lot of urine, so - flick.
But why flick drops? Cicadas, fellow xylem
feeders and cousins of sharpshooters,
spray their urine in a much more conventional
way - so why not sharpshooters. Well micro-ct
scans and studies using high-speed cameras are
revealing exactly what's going on and it turns
out the answer all comes down to size and energy.
Sharpshooters are tiny and at this scale water is,
for want of a better word, sticky. Sharpshooters
would risk being engulfed in their own pee if they
didn't find a way to jettison it, but when you're
that small creating a jet of water uses a lot
of energy. Far more than the teeny sharpshooters
could muste,r so they took a different approach.
The urine is gently squeezed into a droplet which
perches on hydrophobic hairs at the tip of an
appendage called a stylet. the sharpshooters
then pull back the stylet like a spring and
release it flinging the drops with incredible
speed. But the droplets don't just move fast,
they move 40% faster than the stylet does.
This phenomenon is called super-propulsion,
but how does it work? Well imagine a diver
bouncing on a diving board. As the board bends it
stores energy then releases it as it bounces back
up. If the dive then times a jump at the right
moment they can make use of the energy stores in
the board to amplify that jump, traveling higher
and faster. And it turns out something similar
is happening with the sharpshooter. Much like the
diving board tiny water droplets have the capacity
to deform and store energy in surface tension. As
the stylet then moves it compresses the droplet
which then bounces back - time it exactly right
right and this bounce back amplifies the force of
the stylet and the droplet flies away at a greater
speed. Modeling has shown that achieving this
effect requires extremely accurate timing - too
slow or too fast and you risk the bounce back
actually counteracting the force of the stylet,
slowing down the flick. And yet sharpshooters
appear remarkably capable of hitting the right
rhythm every single time - saving them energy and
allowing them to keep feeding. Super-propulsion Is
not a new concept in the lab but the team behind
this work say that this is the first time it's
been seen in a natural system and that similar
approaches could be used to remove unwanted
water from devices, like smartphones or smart
watches. All inspired by the humble sharpshooter.